[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we're here with chappelle
lacey hey hey
aka bouncer no i don't know i don't know
it's gonna stick but i like it
one thing i wanted to ask you guys is
was there ever something that you
hardcore believed in
that no you no longer do
either because someone told you it
wasn't true and you were i was christian
that's a big thing yeah and you really
believed it back then like you were
strong with it well because i was born
into it yeah so i had no other choice
that was my you didn't know anything
else yeah i was like
everyone that doesn't go to church on
saturday is going to hell dog that was
you that was your heart yeah because i'm
like because we're a part of this uh i
had the same thing in my offshoot
christianity group called the
seventh-day adventists
and then you know it's not shout-out to
the offshoots yeah but they're usually
the offshoot ones are more hardcore dude
you know this is true have you guys seen
that doc uh keep sweet no no about the
offshoot lds no
no no
what is it on what is on that it's on
netflix
yeah it's about this dude i forget the
guy's name oh gosh he was you say nick
for now
he's my name is a placeholder well
basically he was on the blanks he was he
had they all had like multiple wives but
they were oh that's not me pretty much
breeding them like at a young age oh
like they were like there was 32 year
olds like marrying like 14 year olds so
they were in their own they were in this
like their own compound what state
though uh this was in utah yeah and then
that's okay then he tried to move this
[ __ ] to like texas warren buffs
buffs is the guy's name whoa not buffett
warren buffett's wait is it warm
it's warren buffett no let's say his
name is warren buffs
isn't his name
is his name warren buffet
buffet my bad that's the right one but
they were like hardcore about the
religion but they basically used it
as like manipulation right yeah and it
was just like more of like a
sexual [ __ ] but there's still people
that still strongly believe they're
still in it yeah i think even though
even though they caught the dude they
caught all these tapes of him you know
they're like uh voice recordings of him
hooking up with
wow
voice recordings i did see this one yeah
it's like from way back right yeah yeah
wow no we were more like a what's the
opposite of a sex cult
celibate cult yeah like nobody was
[ __ ] the virgin the whole body was
[ __ ] yeah we were opposite of this
but sometimes that means that there's
hella [ __ ] going on behind closed
doors
it was dry you guys know about the waco
texas stuff yeah oh yeah religion i know
a little bit of that that religion is an
offshoot from ours yeah oh really really
i didn't know that it's an offshoot
isn't that something davidian or
something yeah the davidians they were
that guy was seventh-day adventist and
then he made his own [ __ ] yeah wow
that's what they do yes that's how the
offshoots start they keep [ __ ]
splitting and splitting yeah and then
take people with them and then they have
this thing nah we're just more like a
like like a vegetarian cult you know
what i mean like it's just let's just
see some [ __ ] vegetables
and then just go [ __ ] praise and what
was the turn what was the turning point
for you to stop believing in this yeah i
think i was always a very curious kid
that kept asking so many questions that
i got my ass beat because i just
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up and ask
and then like i kept asking questions
and i would obsess over the answers that
i didn't feel satisfied with so then i'm
like why i'm like i don't understand
like i would ask questions like why do
we have to work
like in elementary school right
yeah well because they'll say
i don't want to go to school i mean i
want to go to see my friends i don't
know if i can go do homework but then
i'll tell my parents i'll be like why do
i got to go to school because you need
to work and i'm like why do i gotta work
why do you have to work why can't those
are hard questions because there's
people in the jungle or like we learned
about like indians and cowboys and did
they work like i don't think so right
pirates didn't work they just [ __ ]
stole it
they didn't no like and then you watch
disney movies and [ __ ] the [ __ ]
princess all day is just chilling
getting swept off her feet and [ __ ] yeah
you never see her going into the diner
and [ __ ] yeah joe's like i'm trying to
be a princess right
working that overnight racing doesn't
work that much either a bunch of dead
beats they don't do anything stab me
dude so then i would go to church and i
would ask people at church like why do i
have to work what i got to go do why do
we have to go to church right uh because
you have to believe in god why so you
could go to heaven why like why do i
want to go to heaven and then you learn
things about how
your friends who are not seventh-day
adventists your friends who go to church
on sundays everybody else is going to
help and i didn't like people at church
so i'm like all the people that i
[ __ ] actually love are going to hell
and i'm like well i want to go to hell
too
that's so crazy i have a similar [ __ ]
sister had a similar situation with it
not it wasn't i mean it was kind of
regular christianity or whatever but i
just regularly because
no offenses
when i went to church camp you know my
adopted folks you know because they're
strong in the christian faith and they
wanted to send me to the church camp and
i was like okay i'll go to that [ __ ]
what's up with it and prior to that you
weren't going to church no no
i mean heaven no i'm just kidding
no i so i uh go to this church camp and
it was just [ __ ] weird right off the
gate i was like what the [ __ ] is this i
was like in i was watching these people
like sit there and like you know praise
jesus in a way and cry but meanwhile
all these [ __ ] was on drugs
like not all of them but like some of
them but hypocrisy the hypocrisy is what
caught me off guard and then then they
were then then they had the nerves to be
like
do you they're like do you believe
jesus christ died on the cross you know
whatever
that
maybe if i took the same [ __ ] you did
if i was on molly and then they were
like they're right because they're like
because they're like before you answer
you know
if you don't believe this you're going
to hell yeah and i was like bro you're
just a dude in [ __ ] khaki shores who
are you
yeah
and he's like jesus wore sandals
[Laughter]
the certainty always freaked me the [ __ ]
out yeah yeah that i know for sure you
are going to [ __ ] hell bro that's
what i'm saying like i'm like who are
you to tell chill the [ __ ] out a little
bit
and it's so tyrannical because they
somehow want to be like the gatekeeper
like i talk to god you don't yeah and so
it's like i know [ __ ] more than you
and therefore you have you're accessing
it throughout
that's not
my connection with god like that's just
you trying to be an authoritative figure
trying to tell me so then in junior high
i was like man [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm gonna
smoke weed and like also when i [ __ ] you
guys
when i got kicked out of christian
school um
for the second time the school that we
went to right
i was like i thought christians were
trying were supposed to like counsel and
help those that are like in need but
then everywhere i went i just felt like
ostracized and blamed and then possessed
by the devil so i'm like well [ __ ] it
then if i'm a part of the hell group
then i guess i'm with the devil you know
dude and that was my thing i was like i
don't feel like i'm being a bad person
like i don't feel like i got to do
anything crazy like i wasn't malicious
to people like i wasn't trying to they
probably just didn't like the way you
dressed or like they didn't like the way
you thought and it's like you didn't
really sin but they treated you like one
yeah i remember one time
you know i went to church with my homie
and his family and i
uh rolled up to his crib uh to meet up
with him to drive to church and i wore a
misfit's shirt and then it's like the
fiends yeah
and his mom sat me down
and talked to me and basically was like
do you know why this is wrong
and made me change
she's like my shirt is way better
[Laughter]
legendary legendary shouts out to corn
though
but then meanwhile like her husband has
like a t-shirt on with the punisher
skull with an american flag going
through the eyes yeah it's like that's
what i'm saying like it's like okay
which is super cool steve yeah the
inconsistency and i'm not against
religion or anything like that like i
mean if that's what you find to deliver
your best self then [ __ ] do that but
also don't [ __ ] sit here and tell
people they're going to hell because
they don't believe yeah what you believe
you know that's like that's pretty much
how did you did you
take the shirt off and everything
yeah
[ __ ] i was out of respect huh out of
respect yeah and see and i was being a
nice guy yeah yeah yeah was there
anything what am i doing now [ __ ] no i'd
be like suck it up
[ __ ] you mom
is there anything uh is there anything
non-religious that you guys might have
believed in hardcore and then yeah i
have one so um when i was a kid
uh i any time i ever heard of any dude
hitting a chick
i ruled it as dishonorable and i would
never talk to that person on my desk oh
wow
but now
i was like this is the one you wanted to
go with this is the one you wanted to go
with
he sets it up like but you know what i
think it's a great idea
notice all of us started backing up
now it's honorable
it's the most honorable thing you can do
to put it out there since i've switched
my belief i have never hit any chicks
ever [ __ ]
you won't do it you won't do it but that
was i i realized that was like a very
idealistic
uh young thought
because as i got older i've seen chicks
push dudes like a [ __ ] okay geo
like
like hit me
and they're like hitting them right yeah
hit me hit me [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] you only gonna do [ __ ]
whatever and me seeing that and i'm like
and then having seen uh
like the dude actually lay one hand down
and then drop the chick and i'm like
dude
that's what exactly what you're asking
for and then also
and also
continue this is going really well
i don't know we're gonna hear you out
we're gonna hear you out going into what
time where
there we go are supposed to be equal
right i'm like if we're trying to be
equal then we can't have this double
standard that means everyone can catch
these hands so
is that is that what you just say
like girl you can run we can run this
fade right now 10 second bodies
like i don't i don't have that same
judgment whereas before like let's say
if i found out anthony hit his chicks
hey just say nick just say nick
but now if if i found out anthony i
looked on a chick before i'm like we
could still be it doesn't change your
view you're like whoop that trick oh man
which is something i never thought in
like my life i would ever see it that
way hey man i just think that [ __ ] was
wack but now i get it it's kind of sad
i like how you just [ __ ] dig
so it's good that bart went down because
now we could say anything we did yeah
yeah i know right yeah yeah that was he
was he took doors yeah anybody else i
never saw no chicks no of course of
course but he endorses the beating of
women but you're like the homies could
do it i ain't gonna do it but the homies
can do it no you know what it was
actually at a i think it was a video at
a steelers game where this dude he was
trying he was trying not like this woman
was getting booked with a big black dude
too and she was like getting buck with
him and in his face and she [ __ ] hits
him and he just slapped her and his
[ __ ] like sean connery and i was like
you kind of you kind of hit him first
yeah cause she was like all up in his
face she wouldn't stop and just
and then he was just like yeah when
someone pushes you to a point to where
and then they start hitting you it's
like yo you [ __ ] put your hands on me
i mean you should never really i mean
but he wasn't he wasn't trying to go any
further after that first hit yeah like
that was more like yo back [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know like like for for comedy
purposes bart can always endorse guys to
hit you know women but in reality i
think like
i think in reality i don't want to be
the jared is funding it yeah you want to
be the jerry yeah i don't want to bug a
bee selling
making commercials and [ __ ] i get scared
sitting in between these two there's a
lot of energy
fix it anthony fix it
but but but in reality though like i
think like okay there are
cases
where
where um let's like there there's a
domestic abuse situation where
uh you know guys are you know being
treated like violently by their spouses
right yeah they never report it and then
um
they'll remember her
there you go but yeah but let's say they
retaliate because they're sick and tired
of getting hit all the time
but then it leaves a bruise she calls
the cop
of course he should never hit her you
know but then he did finally hit her and
then now he's the one going to jail
there's so many cases like that but then
before it's like
you wouldn't ever think that that would
happen because it's always guys wrong
girls are bad yes yeah yeah yeah you
ever see that one with the bus driver he
overcut that girl
yeah
you're going to jail now
you feel like a dragonfish
she was asking for that one oh that one
that was that was [ __ ] street fighter
that's bartholomew
he's like you know what he's part of the
defeat all women's side
that's his side right
now hey
hey my name is you just told your
favorite uppercut [ __ ] music story
i'm talking about
i'll go sit over there
yeah this sport's hard to cry what is
this
it's like okay now you share your
favorite violence against women's story
yeah let's go around the room i will say
i will say chris brown taught me that
you could get away with it
boy this is always great
you have to do a lot hey he said that
one you said that it's because i'm on
this side
double jeopardy i was already getting
framed for it thank you for subscribing
to the fresh and fit podcast
oh my god
we're [ __ ] andrew tate over here man
we're a bunch of top g's over here do
you have anything
like hitting women yes
do you have any uh
criminal records
like there's nothing you like hardcore
believed in when you're in college
you thought viets were superior anything
like that
still does
i agree i agree definitely not when were
you ever a bigot
most of your life probably okay yeah ah
that's a good question i'm trying to
think that's a good question we should
reframe this like to like actually
really think about like what you for
real hardcore believed in and then
change yeah because like in bart's case
it's the reverse like he became like a
woman beater right so like for in your
case like when did you yeah what was
your one i used to be like you know what
like i'm i'm open but now i'm closed bar
do you realize the door you opened
or closed
but he opened the door for other beaters
she opened
[Laughter]
he was looking for something a little
more easy having a religion you know i
was like you have religion
you could have done politics you could
have done i used to be a [ __ ] you
know
i only believed that the democrats were
the best i got i got one bart's
challenging i used to think some chicks
weren't asking for it
you just copied bart
yeah i used to think that big time but
then but then one day i realized yeah
start talking about some people
definitely are asking
that's a gift man he just passed you
know yeah you're safe he's just ally i
used to think no meant no but it
actually meant
do me harder
[Music]
jesus christ that makes sense how did we
get here
i don't know man i'm still alive we were
talking about christian school so now
you gotta talk what he just said holy
[ __ ] whatever joe just said you gotta
top it because i don't because it's it's
funny as you go through life you forget
that you believed in certain [ __ ] yeah
because there's no way that your beliefs
stay the [ __ ] thing like it changes
the [ __ ] but you just don't remember
like what did i used to think because
you just get moated so hard you like
forget about it right dude i feel like
i've been mowed in my whole [ __ ] life
yeah especially when you're born into
something yeah yeah like well i i grew
up with as the youngest of my group and
my family and my sisters were probably
six seven years older than me and they'd
constantly be dunking on me anything i
said
i just grew up with this uncertainty
about everything yeah you know like
going back to the the whole uh when you
guys talking about christianity
i went to a christian school when i was
in sixth grade i didn't know anything
about the [ __ ] religion i've never
seen a bible before
i didn't know like i kind of heard the
phrase jesus christ but i was like oh
yeah he's like you know but then he
always followed with has dreads so
shake-up yeah yeah and i would do i'd be
super in a barrier rap and [ __ ]
but i went to this school
and all these kids would be talking to
me about like oh yeah you should accept
jesus as your lord and savior and the
whole time i was like
all right cool
just going along yeah and they're like
dude it's sick like heaven
isn't that crazy
and i was in sixth grade and i was like
oh yeah that sounds cool yeah i'll do
that and then as i was going through
like like the bible study like i took
all the stories as like literal
and i would just be like
oh like the jonah and the whale thing i
remember like vividly i had a really
hard time like understanding what the
whole [ __ ] story was yeah and the
whole time whale ate them yeah i was
like what is this dude like i had no
concept of these stories you should have
watched pinocchio that helped me
understand it i never even [ __ ]
watched pinocchio monstro yeah it's the
best version of jonathan is that the
motherfucker's name yeah yeah
monstrous uh the whale and gerpetto oh i
have one it's a it's an odd one though
oh that's perfect should i do it yeah
it's not just listen oh yeah you're
right i mean
he's like it's all one it's not that i
beat children
well okay so when i was younger
i dealt with like identity issues on a
racial level level because i was like
the only black kid yeah that was like
listening to punk and all that [ __ ]
right and so all these people like every
day were telling me i wasn't black wait
you were oh that's fine oh you didn't
grow up here no because there's a hell
of black kids that were into punkin
where was this yeah arizona arizona yeah
yeah yeah so like for the longest time
yeah i believed that yeah that you
weren't black like you weren't blacking
out but i didn't think i was white i was
like
[Music]
but you felt like you lost your black
card
you felt like you lost your black card i
guess like that or i don't know i just
didn't you know and i was i had an
insecurity
being around black people um
you know did you start playing did you
listen to hip-hop like it wasn't just
specific uh
like it wasn't just like black kids
saying it was everybody oh like
everybody was saying so it gave you like
imposter syndrome or something what's
that mean you know it's like like p you
you think that you don't belong
somewhere because everyone sees that
you're a fake
like you think you're gonna be exposed
to any minute yeah well but also i
didn't feel like i was being fake i feel
like i was just i just like it and then
but yeah i feel like i just like [ __ ]
that i liked yeah but i didn't i didn't
think like but other people are labeling
those things as like white yeah things
to like and black things like exactly
like i was just like oh no the
skateboard is cool like no that's white
people [ __ ] dude you can't be doing that
that's how they looked at it though you
know
yeah that's how they looked at me it
never gets hard for you could always
come to the asians we're cool man i know
right asians had the same thing when i
grew up though if you're not listening
to r b trans and tupac and if you listen
to anything else you're just white i
said we're cool joe
the asians are cool joe
it depends if you have gangsters
back to the 19th century
yeah he's like no now you could come in
but i was like in 2003 yeah i don't know
bro but i'm telling you it was it was it
was a crazy moment of time but yeah for
the longest time
i just didn't think
like there was any anything about me
that was was black were you able to find
another like black friend that also
liked these things in arizona um i mean
they would but no one liked it to the
extent that i liked it like i was really
into this [ __ ] like i was going to all
the shows like anything and everything i
could i was just like
yeah all that stuff did you did you try
to connect to your black side somehow
and be like i gotta go like do something
black like listen to tupac or something
no you know what no because i but but i
already said black activity but i
already already listened to rap
um you know what i mean so like that was
the weird part but punk was like the
thing that was like your favorite the
that was the that was number one but
when you go to palm shows you you don't
meet any other like black people at the
point you know what's weird
is when you a black person seen another
black person at a punk show
they're like
oh [ __ ] i'm the only one that could you
know [ __ ] you
but that's not their fault not even i'm
the only black one in their head they're
white but you got to realize it's not
their fault
because because i really don't give a
[ __ ] i'm like hey man hey hey we're both
here
you undercover too yeah right here
we're talking to earpieces
but no the thing is is like what would
make it's not their fault because
whatever group or whoever they're around
makes them feel like
token
they feel
so yeah then they get territorial like
i'm supposed to be the only black guy so
that's a real thing that man because
like movies always make fun of that like
it's a real [ __ ] thing i heard that
from asians that grew up in white
neighborhoods
when they see another asian they they go
like way like you're the only asian guy
in that crew i'm the only asian guy in
this crew like and then they have this
like but wait that was my role yeah
that's so weird man you guys got a beef
yeah how many rock bands you listen to
like it's like
yeah i don't think it's i don't think
it's as much now because i feel like you
know things have opened up a lot more
yeah but
you know there was a period of time
where like i strongly believed that and
it was just like that i was like this is
i guess this is just my life
you know you know lag wagon yeah i just
saw them live in [ __ ] orange county
really yeah like
that outdoor spot yeah yeah the nights
at will smith
uh slap chris rock damn yeah it was
second historical night i know you like
lag wagon uh well nicki's into it and i
went with her brother and yeah this one
yeah that's cool oh yeah so yeah that's
the
thanks for sharing thanks for sharing
thanks for sharing dude mark thank you
for
laughing
bart i mean
suck the [ __ ] out of this camera
[Music]
you